foreign
's leadership campaign he's a close
friend of the prime minister so no
surprises that Oliver Dowden is now back
in cabinet with a critical role because
as Chancellor the dusty of Lancaster
he's responsible for coordinating
delivery across government and he joins
us now thank you very much for being
with us this morning
um let's start off with a bit of good
news shall we or some would take news
we're going to get an extra bank holiday
yes it's fantastic news and I think that
the coronation is a mixture of the
Sacred and the solemn it's the crowning
of our new king but also it's a moment
for celebration and just as we did with
the coronation some 70 years ago there's
another opportunity for the nation to
come together whether that's as families
or communities to celebrate our new king
and I think it will be a fantastic
occasion they cost money they don't know
bank holidays
uh well of course there is some cost
associated with it in terms of
factories and so on not operating but
there's a huge boost for example to
hospitality and tourism but really the
key Point here is that this is our new
king the first time we've had a new king
crown for 70 years and I think most
people up and down the country would
want to take an opportunity to to
celebrate it and I think it's right that
we should have a bank holiday
and talk a bit more about what we can
expect from a Russia studentac
Premiership but before we'll get to that
there's a story in the Sunday newspapers
that we do need to discuss Gavin
Williamson at the cabin office Minister
and he's working of course in your
department now he is being investigated
for alleged bullying and intimidating
Behavior toward Wendy Morton the former
Chief whip astonishingly it seems that
this was all about the fact that he
hadn't been invited to the funeral of
the queen and these uh messages that are
in the Sunday Times this morning include
him saying it's disgusting that you're
using her death to punish people he
obviously thought that she wasn't giving
him an invite for political reasons he
said let's see how many more times you
is all over there is a price for
everything what's your reaction takes
messages
well that these were sent In the Heat of
the Moment uh expressing frustration uh
it was a difficult time for the party I
think he now accepts that he shouldn't
have done it and he regrets doing so and
I think that that's right and thankfully
we're in a bit of a better place now as
a party
it sounds a bit threatening there
doesn't it there's a price for
everything what's that supposed to mean
well remember this was uh Gavin
winnerson when he was a backbencher
expressing his frustrations at a
difficult time for the party with the
then Chief whip he regrets the language
that he uses and I don't think he should
have used that that sort of language but
nonetheless that that is in the past now
and now thankfully we're in a better
place as a party it's not very long ago
it's not like it was three years ago it
was just a you know a matter of kind of
weeks ago if you like and also you know
most people would look at this and say
okay everyone gets frustrated at work
most people wouldn't send those kind of
messages to a colleague does British
sunic have confidence in him well he
shouldn't have sent those messages and
he says that he regrets it but of course
the the Prime Minister continues to have
confidence in Gavin Williamson as a
minister Okay so Jake Berry the former
party chair says that he told Rishi
sunak about this complaint the day
before he was appointed to the cabinet
is that true
well I don't think it was any secret
that Gavin Williamson and other back
benchers had a difficult relationship
with the chief whip but it's not this
was he told it
um it is not the case that the Prime
Minister saw this exchange of text
messages and until they were leaked to
newspapers last night but he was aware
of the allegation well he was aware that
there were there was a difficult
relationship between the chief Whip and
a number of back benches of which Gavin
Williamson was but did he know that she
had accused uh the former Chief Gavin
Williamson bullying her to know that
allegation well he knew that there was a
difficult relationship between them now
clearly there is a complaints process
which is ongoing at the conservative
party which I'm not part and I I can't I
can't cut across that individual
complaint did he know the complaint had
been made well the the Prime Minister
knew that there was a difficult uh
relationship and I think because as
you've said well I think as you've seen
from the the former chairman Jake Berry
he says that he highlighted that to the
the Prime Minister but in terms of these
specific uh allegations this specific
exchange the Prime Minister wasn't aware
of it until last night um I just want to
look at Gabby Williamson's career and
this is a man who kept a tarantula in
his desk when he was Chief whip he was
fired as defense secretary by Theresa
May for leaking sensitive National
Security information he was then fired
as education secretary by Boris Johnson
over the exams Fiasco during covid he
was put back in the cabinet by Rishi
sunak and then immediately caught an
alleged bullying scandal you know what
was it about Gavin Williamson's record
in government that made origin sooner
think yes I want that man in my cabinet
well I actually think you can see in the
the government that Richie sunac formed
as prime minister he brought together
people from all across the conservative
party he brought supporters of Liz tras
he brought supportive Boris Johnson he
brought people that supported on him on
his campaign and I think Gavin
Williamson has paid a big part in the
the conservative party and I think it's
right that he should be as part of that
team that brings together all parts of
the conservative party so it's got
nothing to do with the fact that he
played an instrumental role in where she
seen its campaign to become Prime
Minister well I think you can see in the
the government that Rishi soon that he
was bringing together all different
parts of the conservative party and
Gavin forms part of that okay
now let's move on shall we you are
incredibly close to the prime minister
of course I know you're going to be
plugged into what we can expect from
originally Premiership he's talked a lot
about leveling with the public about the
difficult decisions ahead so really I
guess this is your opportunity to do
that
should we be bracing ourselves for a
return to austerity well we Face very
difficult times as a country not least
because of Russia's illegal invasion of
Ukraine and as we recover from covid and
at the heart of that the Prime Minister
and the chancellor Jeremy Hunt have put
restoring stability and that's
absolutely essential because for example
if we allow inflation to get out of
control mortgage rates get out of
control everyone is going to suffer and
the poorest will suffer the worst so
it's right that we take difficult
decisions I have to say to to you and
your viewers there will be unfortunately
more significant difficult decisions to
come in the Autumn statement the week
after next but at the same time at the
heart of all of that as the Prime
Minister demonstrated during covid
compassion is at the heart of of what
he's doing and protecting the most
vulnerable and I think those are the
parameters of that Autumn statement it
is about difficult decisions but also
protecting the most vulnerable should
most of us expect to be paying more tax
well I think we're going to have to face
difficult decisions both on the the tax
side we haven't got to the end of the
difficult decisions there and difficult
decisions on the spending side now of
course in terms of the the specific
decisions that will be made that
conversation is ongoing between the the
Prime Minister and the chancellor and
you wouldn't expect any government
minister to comment before the the
Autumn statement I know you're saying
what you can't comment Sunday Telegraph
saying the chancellor is looking at
reducing pension tax relief for higher
earners is that part of the discussion
well so if you you've you've been around
these events many times as I have been
there's an awful lot of speculation in
in the newspapers some of it's correct
some of it's not correct uh I can't go
into any individual uh stories but what
I can say is it is the case that will be
difficult decisions in that that Autumn
statement and previously with austerity
we saw the focus on spending cuts but it
is right it seems from what Youth and
others have said that actually tax Rises
are going to form a bigger part than
previously
I I wouldn't I wouldn't say this between
tax versus spending cuts we've got uh
unfortunately because of the difficult
decisions that we have to take we're
going to have to take difficult
decisions on both tax and spending but
of course as conservatives and I know
that the the Prime Minister and the
chancellor share this view with me we
need to Bear Down on spending first and
eliminate waste excessive spending and
only go to tax Rises if it's a last
resort but given the difficulty of the
public finances there is likely to be a
mix of the two and what can you give us
any you know what kind of that mix may
be 50 50
in favor it's not uh it's not
appropriate to get into the the detail
of that balance and indeed those
conversations are ongoing between the
premises we've been talking a lot about
tax cuts so far I just want to look a
little bit at spending because we went
to uh Bradford for the show this week at
correspondent at Fraser Maude Liz truss
of course promised to build Northern
Powerhouse Royal in full including a 43
billion pound High Speed Line Between
Leeds Liverpool and Bradford I just want
to play you what people were talking to
us about when we went to Bradford
I don't think it's gonna happen to get
from leads to Manchester takes over an
hour and costs more than 40 pounds of
return Journey it's impractical to not
have the two biggest most Financial
Centers in the north not linked together
by over an hour
do you think they're committed to
updating the north no they haven't got
no thoughts about that at all they're
not thinking oh so oh they don't pop
your bums and get up here and see what
they can do for us
University students talked a lot about
the Mandate from the 2019 election all
about leveling up all about leveling up
outside of London and you can see there
from Bradford people are really worried
you're going to go back on it well we're
committed to honoring our 2019 Manifesto
and leveling up performs the heart of it
and indeed that was a Manifesto that was
agreed uh by by the Prime Minister ended
by me and other members of the cabinet
with the Prime Minister we remain fully
committed to honoring our Manifesto uh
commitments however of course that is in
the context of a very difficult uh
financial situation but I can assure you
that the Autumn statement will continue
our commitment to to leveling up
including Northern Powerhouse rail in
full well it's it's tempting to get
drawn into each and every uh
announcement I've said that difficult
decisions will have to be taken but but
in taking those difficult decisions we
will be very cognizant of the duty that
we owe to people that voted to us for us
often for the first time in 2019 back to
Manifesto that included leveling up and
you will see leveling up being honored
in that manifestation statement No
Russia is going uh to cop the climate
Summit in Egypt he's pledged to make the
UK a clean energy superpower he's also
talked about ending our dependence on
fossil fuels are you still planning to
issue more than 100 new drilling license
licenses for oil and gas in the North
Sea well I think it is the case that
when we Face a a challenge with oil and
gas supply particularly after the
invasion of the Ukraine by Russia and
the effect that that's had on oil price
and Global oil and gas supply we should
look to make sure that we continue to
provide oil and gas from our own
resources but that's not to say we're in
any way going soft on Renewables and
actually if you look at our records of
government since 2010 according to
different estimates we've had between a
four and five-fold increase in
Renewables they're now about 40 of our
electricity Supply and we're going to
continue to press ahead with that
whether that's with huge investment on
an offshore wind or or other measures
you say offshore wind
um but when it comes to onshore wind you
are making it much harder effectively
banning at new onshore uh wind and you
know if you're serious about climate a
change you want to make the UK clean
energy superpower why are you running
back on onshore wind and drilling more
in the North Sea well we're not going
back on on Shore wind it has been the
case I think for about eight or ten
years that we made sure that local
residents views are properly taken into
account in respect of onshore wind
actually you can get huge amounts of
Renewables from offshore the UK has
become a global leader in offshore and
we've increased the Renewables as part
of the energy mix by about fivefold why
we've been government and I think that's
the right balance making sure that we
recognize local feelings but at the same
time investing in Renewables now the
summit that's going on in Egypt later on
the program we are going to be talking
to the sister of Allah adolfata who is a
British Egyptian human rights campaigner
Defender he's been held in jail on
Hunger Strike his sister is calling on
the UK government to try and do more to
personally talk to the Egyptian
president to secure his release and what
can you tell us about that case
well it's a very difficult case and it
has been raised by the UK government at
every level and I understand that the
foreign secretary raised it with his
Egyptian opposite number uh very
recently clearly I'm not going to get
into individual conversations that the
Prime Minister may have while he's at
the summit but I know the prime minister
is very much aware of it and will raise
it as appropriate okay I will be talking
to the sister later in the program to
get her reaction as well now
I'm interested to talk to you about your
role in government because you're in
charge of resilience planning which of
course with the winter approaching is
ever more important now the National
Grid has warned that there could be
blackouts if temperatures drop sharply
if Russia of course cuts off gas and oil
surprise uh to Europe have you been
wargaming at what to do if there are
these blackouts well I I leave the
cabinet office which is in a way the
sort of HQ of government we we deal with
coordination across government and of
course we look at all different
scenarios it is going to be a a
challenging winter and of course we we
look at the situation in respect of
energy Supply I have to say that having
looked at and I know that
um my my colleague in in Bays Grant
chaps is is very much across this as
well we have got a robust resilience
plans and I would very much hope that we
would not find ourselves in the sort of
extreme situation that you describe you
obviously hope it doesn't happen but
what do those resilience plans look like
I mean there's been talk about National
Grid saying there could be three hour
blackouts between four to seven PM in a
worst case scenario is that accurate
well I'm not going to comment on
individual scenarios described what I
would say though is that uh the sort of
Extreme Measures that would see a lack
of Supply are are very much at the
uh the the more unlikely scale of these
things happening so I I would say to
your viewers and and to you that uh that
certainly should not be their their
expectation of what would happen this
winter we do have uh robust resilience
plans in place
um another thing that we are perhaps
more likely to see uh is strikes almost
certain to see uh strikes uh in
different sectors and there are reports
in The Observer Today that nurses have
voted to strike for the first time uh
nationally in their history what kind of
an impact could that have on the Health
Service well first of all we don't know
whether that that is the case and I very
much hope it doesn't turn out to be the
case we have well oiled contingencies in
place and the Department of Health is
across how we would deal with a scenario
like that should it arise and clearly
we'll make sure that we prioritized the
most essential Services emergency
services and so on but of course the the
would be an impact as a result of a
strike like that now continue to urge
nurses and others to to resist going out
on strike even if if they have voted to
do so I know these are difficult times
but but we have already agreed quite
considerable support for nurses what
would the impact be
well that would depend on the individual
hospitals and the scale of the adherence
to the strike but there are there are
well well all mechanisms in place to
make sure that we seek to minimize as
much as possible the the disruption to
to people particularly those in them the
most need but of course if you're in the
situation where you have a large number
of nurses going out on strike of course
that is going to have an impact for
example on some elective surgery and
other activities by hospitals it's just
inevitable given the the numbers
involved and of course the NHS right now
already are under pressure I just want
to have a look at the current picture
for a e waiting times this is actually
quite shocking when I saw this graph I
can actually really believe it this is
people who are waiting 12 hours or more
in a e and the red line at the top is
2022 and September 32 776 people waited
more than 12 hours that's the highest
number in records go back to August
2010. I mean this this is this looks
like a you know a Health Service that is
really on the brink here
yes we have very big challenges with the
Health Service
um it was only a year ago that we had a
global
pandemic and you can see well if you
look at those numbers how that is
driving the the rise in pressure on uh a
d it's still coming up and and others
yes of course not now in 2022. well
first of all because
those those effects don't stop when the
pandemic the pandemic hasn't even
stopped but but as the the effects of
the pandemic Abate it is the case that
the backlogs continue to increase for
some time that is why the government is
investing record sums into the NHS and
the new health secretary Steve Barkley
is absolutely appraised of what we need
to do to make sure that we start to to
Bear down these numbers for example uh
just this week we've agreed an extra
half billion pounds 500 million pounds
worth of support to help through this
winter period to to address exactly this
sort of problems there's a complex range
of factors for example access to to GP
Services delayed discharges uh in
relation to to social care okay and I
know that the the health sector indeed
the Prime Minister have got a grip
across the board on this a quick thought
from you for your of course has been by
Rishi sunak's side uh during a roller
coaster uh year do you think that he
ever thought that he would have a second
chance
and I don't think he did and in a way I
don't think he would have wanted to have
had this situation where he came in in
such difficult times but I think he and
I and indeed the whole cabinet feel a
very profound sense of uh National Duty
and and getting on with the job of
dealing with the challenges that this
country faces and I can tell you that's
exactly what he's seized of every minute
of the day okay thank you very much for
being on the program at Oliver Dowden
there